hi my name is Aaron Harris I'm a partner
here at Y Combinator and I spent a lot
of time thinking about sin Tech and how
technology is changing the way we use
and move money and how that plays into
assets banking systems insurance systems
which all kind of comes together for a
lot of people in cryptocurrency which is
obviously this new not super new but
fairly new in the context of money and
financial systems set of things and I
think there's a lot of misunderstanding
about it so I'm happy we're doing a
bunch of podcasts talking to people who
really get this stuff because I have a
ton to learn so I'll often really super
excited to talk to you about this
because you get it way better than I do
yeah so thanks for having me my name is
Olaf Carlson we I'm the founder of poly
chain capital which is the largest
blockchain investing hedge fund in the
world far before poly chain capital I
found out about Bitcoin in the summer of
2011 and became extremely infatuated
with this concept of digital assets I
decided to pen my undergraduate thesis
on Bitcoin that year I think this was
probably one of the first academic works
on cryptocurrency after that I joined
coinbase as the first employee coinbase
was actually a Y Combinator company and
is now raising money purportedly at over
1 billion dollar valuation I was at
claim B's for three and a half years and
during that time I was the head of risk
I was also paid exclusively in Bitcoin
some day one day one for the entirety of
my time there I was paid exclusively in
Bitcoin so there were good times when
that was a good decision in times when
that was a bad decision but I think net
net it was right and I left last summer
to launch the poly chain fund so we
launched with a little around 4 million
under management and now we have about
200 million under management
we have backing from Union Square
Ventures and recent Horowitz Sequoia and
founders found among others so somewhat
unusual LP base and we can get into that
a little bit are those funds functioning
as
straight LPS are they investing in the
GP they're straight LPS okay so I work
for a hedge fund for a while so I have a
conception of how that looks in my head
the kind of things that you look at but
there are a lot of different kinds of
hedge funds there are macro hedge funds
there are long short funds there are
activist phones what does it mean to be
a hedge fund focused on the blockchain
yeah so a lot of those strategies you
just stated could all apply to
cryptocurrency assets some of them are
mechanically much more difficult so for
example short positions in the space are
difficult to achieve in a secure way
also for example something as simple as
margin trading can be hard to find for
the right assets that you're trying to
trade in for us I were sort of what I
would call fundamental investors in that
we're long only with a long holding
period and I send most of my time
reading research papers about crypto
currencies how long will the holding
period so it really depends on on how
fast things grow so we are rebalancing
the portfolio roughly every 90 days so
the goal is to hold things that are our
good positions for years but we may
rebalance or sell down on those
positions over time okay
so in terms of pace of movement it kind
of looks less like a hedge fund and more
like I think how people would think
about almost a mutual fund kind of thing
but I'm guessing hedge fund because it
allows you a lot more flexibility in
terms of what you're allowed to invest
in and the strategies you can pursue
yeah so the the tricky thing was I knew
in my head what I wanted to do as far as
investing in these assets and that it
actually looks a little bit like a
venture investment in that you find
things extremely early when they're
still just a specification so these
protocol specifications are white papers
are extremely detailed descriptions of
exactly what a protocol will do it's
often very possible to understand a lot
about what this will look like just from
that specification and I often feel
comfortable investing if I meet the team
and I read the specification and really
like what they're doing so that looks
very much like event
investment in that you're investing more
on an idea than you are unproven data
are numbers but from there these
investments very quickly graduate into
liquid markets and so because these
things are liquidly traded on an order
book unlike a venture firm you really
have to balance those positions you
can't just sort of wait for the IPO so
to speak so because of that I I knew we
needed to manage liquidity and I knew we
needed to have really good risk
management around our positions because
we have month-to-month volatility unlike
private equity or venture fund which can
just kind of sit on positions forever
but I wanted to take this this long-term
investing approach that eventually fund
would where a lot of your success is
defined by very very big winners and
positions that that rise substantially
in value so we invest in things at a
really early stage we form really good
relationships with entrepreneurs I'm
really proud of a lot of people we've
backed and then you know hope to hold
those positions for years as this
thing's grown and so can you get dig
into the technical aspect of what you're
actually looking for when you're reading
the white papers yeah so when we're
reading these protocol specifications or
white papers
we're looking for basically a novel
concept or novel idea so this could be a
new application of existing technology
this could be an application of
technology that hadn't been tried in the
cryptocurrency framework before this
could be just a kind of new game
theoretic model that no one had ever
designed before that allows for kind of
a novel incentive system or incentive
structure new consensus systems new just
just kind of like anything in this
category of enabling new behaviors hmm
so you know there's a lot of
technologies out there that are forks of
existing technology so the fork Bitcoin
into something very very similar that's
usually not very interesting for us we
really we really like things that are
served written from the ground up so
like aetherium was not a fork a Bitcoin
nitiram was written from the ground up
Tasos whose crowd tail actually ends
today is also written from the ground up
not a fork of etherium even though it
has a turing-complete scripting language
like aetherium hmm and so when you're
vetting a team given that they're very
few you know cryptocurrencies with a
long track record are you looking for
like how many times have committed to
evaluate them are like what are you
looking for yeah we definitely look at
the codebase I think a lot of it though
you know just pragmatically speaking
like we can't review every line of code
in a new blockchain right that's we we
do require all our investments to get
security audits from you know outside
third parties but even that right these
are often experimental technologies and
they may be broken in unforeseen ways so
there are what I would call unknown
unknowns here there are things that you
you kind of don't know that you don't
know that said I think that I have a
long history of kind of like a coin base
I did probably about 500 interviews I'm
very used to talking with technical
people and getting a sense of their
subject matter expertise I also really
feel comfortable betting on people if
they have a great idea so I think that
it's like seed investing right a lot of
the time you meet a really great
entrepreneur they have a really great
idea and that's basically what you're
investing in so there's a dividing line
or a difference between the technology
being interesting right and being
fundamentally new in some way and there
being a use for that technology down the
road and sometimes the uses are
completely opaque because we don't know
what the technology is going to do to
the world right the the things that you
invest them that do best actually change
the world and create the conditions for
which they will be successful how do you
evaluate that set of things or how do
you think about that set of things yeah
so the interesting thing here is that
most of what we're investing today our
protocol or infrastructure layer things
that really aren't meant to be and use
your applications most of what we're
investing in are really almost like
developer tools to be used for end-user
applications so a lot of what we're
thinking about is what's going to enable
developers more than
is going to be interesting for users but
in that case the developers are your
users so I think it comes back to the
same question of you know do you have a
view of what the world looks like in
five or ten years the things that
developers will need to be able to do
that guide your thoughts on okay this is
not only an interesting technology this
is a cool thing but it will allow this
piece of the future that I believe it
yeah so it's so early in the development
of what I would call web three or this
kind of user owned decentralized web
that oftentimes right now to me it's
pretty clear which things are really
needed and which components of this kind
of infrastructure layer are obvious
value add to developers what are those
so you know for example a project like
file coin which is launching pretty soon
created by whompin a who actually was
also why CEO um file coin is basically
decentralized server client architecture
so a file coin is an incentive layer for
the ipfs server system so ipfs instead
of being location based addressing like
IP addresses it's actually content-based
addressing so when you click a link in
the IP FS network instead of being
routed to a specific server you're
routed to the nearest server that has a
specific piece of content what that
means is that you can have a totally
decentralized architecture where you
have redundant hosting from many nodes
across the network and you pay file coin
in order to submit requests to those
nodes so it's like a distributed server
architecture right now you see a lot of
distributed services say open Bazaar
open bazaars a peer-to-peer marketplace
sort of like a peer-to-peer eBay well
open Bazaar right now as a user you
actually have to download an application
like a dmg to your computer and run it
locally and basically run a node in the
network this is not a great user
experience this means that in web 3
you'd have to download a new application
sort of like it is on mobile instead of
being able to just go to
a URL in the browser with the ipfs
network in place and file coin which
basically adds high uptime and fast
bandwidth and resiliency to the ipfs
network because the absence incentive
layer ipfs is mostly hobbyists right
right now before that file coin
incentive layer gets added then when you
visit opens are in the browser you know
you can have a better user experience
and it's like a more clean experience of
this web 3 so file coin to me becomes a
sort of clear infrastructural component
that's just a huge missing layer here
right now so does that mean that the
basically there's like the use case for
IP FS and file coin is predicated on
open Bazaar being a thing or something
like open Bazaar there will be other
things is then the argument then okay an
open Bazaar is fundamentally a better
solution to the problem of buying and
selling things and today's centralized
systems like eBay if you have to believe
that to be true or is there some other
world in which no these things actually
the side-by-side some people use one
some people use the other and because
the economy is just so damn big and this
thing is just it's all just going to get
bigger there's two winners yeah so I
think that over the long term it's
possible a lot of web 3 services will
compete on costs structures with
centralized services like say eBay but
that's actually less interesting to me
what's interesting is what these kind of
web 3 services do that a normal web
service could not do because the eBay
experience is actually pretty solid for
buyers and sellers it's all smooth I buy
stuff on eBay
I think the fees they charge a
reasonable given they have like services
they you know value add services like
dispute arbitration because all those
sorts of things are kind of then
independent on something like the open
Bazaar platform but I do think there are
going to be web 3 apps that really are
uniquely enabling behavior so types of
things that you really can't get out of
web 2.0 or like the central
as web and this is a hand way the answer
but I do have this intuitive feeling
that we actually don't really know what
a lot of those use cases are and what
we're talking about is services for
things like doubts a doubt here being a
decentralized autonomous organization
that's basically a pooling of capital on
the blockchain when you think about a
Dao pool of capital it can't I don't
think it can realistically engage in
traditional legal arrangements but it
can re you know enter into smart
contract or like software based legal
arrangements so I actually think that
you'll see more and more kind of
services for doused with doubts here
being just basically global pools of
capital that exist only the blockchain
and not a legal entity so these are the
types of things they sound a little bit
sci-fi right now
but I think in five years we could see
some massive massive kind of hurt you
know it's like in in the early internet
I think it was hard to imagine Facebook
right and I think there's this video
I've seen of Marc Andreessen explaining
Netscape in like 1994 and I'm an
audience member says what are some
websites you think are interesting
he really stumbles like he really
struggles to answer the question and he
kind of comes back to well this is
really great technology I know cool
things are going to happen today I don't
really know what to point to and I feel
like pointing to things that are
ostensibly better versions of the
centralized web or efficiency gains on
the centralized web is sort of the easy
path it's kind of like oh let's take
something like a library and put it on
the Internet it'll kind of layer to our
like native internet application is
Wikipedia right which you couldn't
really have in in a non Internet
environment so I think we're going to at
the beginning be comparing or trying to
port rather web to things on to this web
3 or decentralized use your own web but
that over time we'll find those web 3
native applications and those are the
things that I really care about even
though right now they do sound somewhat
sock so I and I think it's there
unclear what they look like yeah I think
there's kind of this the way that I've
tried to think about it and I'd love to
know if this is wrong because it
probably is is that the argument being
made now is sort of that there's this
protein mass of things happening it's
sort of like the primordial goop from
which life originated and the blockchain
technology is being built now are the
early amino acids right we don't know
what's going to happen nothing and it's
entirely possible the whole thing is
going to go to zero right that nothing
will happen out of this attempt but if
you own a piece of the right amino acids
essentially those are going to create
some of something is going to happen
when you have enough creative energy
focused on a small enough surface area
that we will see but yeah but even like
in addition to like some people making
money like I think it makes sense now to
talk about what we were talking about
before we started which is like what are
people not understanding in like what's
covered it how is house cryptocurrency
portrayed in the media and then what are
things that people are essentially
getting wrong we're not covering that
are hurting people from understanding
like the creative power that they might
be able to have so this makes me think
of something that I saw the fall raveh
campus backer of mine tweet and he's a
great thinker in the kind of
cryptocurrency space and he said
something along the lines of you know
bitcoin is you know the the largest fear
of kings and those in power across the
world dressed up as a get-rich-quick
scheme you know something along those
lines and I really do think this idea
that in the mainstream kind of cultural
consciousness crypto currencies I think
mostly are perceived as a get-rich-quick
scheme and I actually think it's kind of
an amazing bootstrapping mechanism to
get a lot of speculation into the space
liquid markets incentives for developers
and ultimately people building on these
technologies so I'm actually not
necessarily against per say a lot of the
speculation happening however I do think
the mainstream media mostly views these
as financial markets that are novel
rather than
novel technologies if that makes sense
what are the key understandings that
people don't get yeah so I mean I think
that these technologies are complicated
so I think a lot of people were reeling
to understand Bitcoin and just the
premise of a blockchain and like right
when they thought they may be understood
it all of a sudden everyone's talking
about aetherium and now they're trying
to wrap their head around a
turing-complete language which can
actually execute arbitrarily complex
software in the blockchain and all of a
sudden this concept of money or currency
is a very limited metaphor for what
these things are doing and kind of you
know what we're going to see is right
when you're kind of starting to
understand aetherium and ERC 20 tokens
which are digital assets built on top of
it cerium that don't have their own
blockchain but are kind of secured by
the etherium Network and it all is kind
of an order of magnitude more complex
than Bitcoin we're now going to see just
even more complicated things happening
where you see Tasos which has on chain
governance where it's an inward-looking
protocol that can actually use protocol
rules to change itself and something
like Cato's can actually build pools of
capital and incentivize developers to
build on the protocol and then sort of
dilute every holder of the Tasos tokens
in order to reward those developers and
so now you have a protocol that
incentivizes development of itself and
this is all like on a native protocol
layer a lot of these things you know
that's like an amazing recursive
feedback loop where the protocol
actually builds itself in in a strange
way but a lot of these things are are
going to be again another order of
magnitude harder to wrap your head
around like things like dows which I
actually think are going to grow a lot
over the next year or two so I think the
kind of technology is always going to be
basically a step ahead of the cultural
understanding of the technology and I
think that's ok I don't expect everyone
to spend their days reading these
protocol specifications and trying to
really wrap their head around it but I
think that if you don't like dive into
the technology and how it works you
just ultimately never really have a deep
understanding of this mm-hmm
so this kind of is relate is one of the
the question someone sent in for you on
Twitter so this is from John light and
he writes most maybe all app coin tokens
are simply used to pay for some resource
like compute hard drive space energy etc
why is a new token needed in these cases
and why can we already use existing
highly liquid tokens like Bitcoin to pay
for these yeah so I think it's actually
a great question from John who actually
know in real life okay so I I think that
the the the disagreement that I would
have is that a lot of people view tokens
from purely from a pure technology
perspective so they think you know we
can do this with Bitcoin and like the
Lightning Network on Bitcoin or
something like that which has a high
throughput layer 2 network so why would
we create a new token and I think there
is no strong reason from a technology
standpoint you could use Bitcoin for a
lot of these different services or a
rather either for a lot of these
different services however when you
create a native token you create a very
different set of incentives so for the
developers who are building that network
you create a real niro incentive around
that application or around that token
right so that it's not just tied to the
larger value of aetherium which if they
kind of contribute this great
application on top of aetherium ether
might grow in value by 5 or 10% but
that's not really a great outcome for
that founder developer in addition the
early backers of that application or
token that's part of this app coin as
john put it aren't if they're just you
know contributing to this product or
service with ether they really don't
have this embedded incentive effect for
that network to grow so um tokens in
this sense are really more of an
incentive structuring or like a a kind
of game theory hack right to get
really powerful Network effects around a
specific application so this is kind of
a rough metaphor but I sensibly you know
in the United States we all sort of
benefit from the strength of the US
dollar but when I create a new company
right I create shares specific to that
company because although even even
though you know I might help us economy
and thus help the US dollar or kind of
the underlying network is you might
think about that
I want narrow Network effects around
what I'm building and so I want my early
backers or investors to have upside
relative to my specific application not
just to the strength of the US dollar so
it's a little bit of a rough metaphor I
don't think it's perfect but I do think
that tokens provide really narrow
Network effects and narrow incentive
effects and that's what's so important
about them it's not really a
technological reason but rather a sort
of game theoretic reason mm-hmm okay so
there there are two arguments baked into
that that I'm not sure how to think
about one of which is the incentive
structure question itself and a lot of
the underlying message here is that
money is at the end of the day the most
the best incentive that you can give
people to develop something and I think
there are very different opinions on
this question and I know people who are
motivated by money and people who aren't
and some of those people on either side
have achieved great things in life both
for themselves and for the human race so
it sort of the first thing like is is
this the right path to say hey we're
going to break everything down
everything that all this fundamental
technology should be motivated around
money the second question that I have is
around this idea of empowering the
collective right to develop new things
and sort of this masked creativity
versus focus creativity and I don't know
that these are in direct opposition to
one another but one of the things you
get with a central authority that does
something and says hey you're worth as
much here with that much there's always
going to be problems with the
distribution of
there but the thing that you get on the
other side is focus of intent which
sometimes is bad when it head in the
wrong direction and sometimes as good
once in sort of a positive direction the
Manhattan Project is like directed focus
on like hey here's the thing that we all
need to do all you great scientists yes
there are subgroups within that but
here's what we're going to do some peers
how you think of both of those things
like in terms of how they incentivize
positive growth I guess and and if those
are the right ways to think about it or
if there's another way that I should
look at this so I think you know I think
we're seeing for the first time
capitalism and like money incentives
being built into open source projects
which I don't think we've ever seen
before I always cringe a little bit
inside when I see the Wikipedia banner
that's sort of like please donate $2 and
I can't help but think there's a world
where Wikipedia was like incentivized
with a token and Jimmy Wales for his
contribution to the world actually
captured a huge amount of value in that
he created a lot of value 80 not capture
a lot of value obviously like having to
go out hat in hand for $2 donations
whereas I think that what we're seeing
now with open source projects is the
creators of something like aetherium
they're creating a huge amount of value
for the world they're also capturing
that value and I think that value
capture is and that kind of adding this
kind of capitalist for-profit mentality
to open source will absolutely
accelerate development in this ecosystem
I just think there I don't have any
question in my mind that monetary
incentives drive growth and and drive
people to work on a project you know
everyone you know or most most amino the
United States like have a job and they
mostly do that for the money at the end
of the day that's like a big driver or
incentive no matter how much someone is
passionate about something if you pulled
out all the money from it it would be
very hard for them to continue doing
that in most cases so I think adding
monetary incentives to this
well it does drawn a sort of different
group of people in some ways than you'd
find in traditional open-source
communities like catching on the Linux
kernel or something I do think that it
ultimately will dramatically increase
the pace of development here ok and then
what about this question about sort of
focused effort versus distributed effort
in terms of you know creativity and like
what should get built yeah so I you know
I have a kind of open market view on
this and in that if you build something
great then a lot of attention and
capital and users will be pushed to what
you build so I don't know if I have a
feeling of like should or like a kind of
moral sense about what should exist but
I do think that there is massive
opportunity right now in that when
people do have a massive breakthrough
the speed at which capital is
coordinating to back their efforts is
absolutely astounding and I think it's
something that is unprecedented we've
never seen before in the world I think
that VCS and early seed investors have
always had this somewhat unique access
to these early stage projects through
their network or something like that I
think that in Silicon Valley we take for
granted that smart people with a good
idea get funded now we're seeing that on
a global scale and we're seeing these
things happen much faster and we're
seeing huge amounts of capital be
coordinated by just pure incentives
around projects so it's early days and
it's hard for me to tell this sort of
cloud sale or so-called ICO fundraising
how this will play out but I do think
over the long term we're actually only
seeing the very very beginning of this
even though crowd sales are now raising
more money than seed round deals in
dollar terms which is kind of astounding
I mean this whole concept of a crowd
sells maybe two years old and really in
the mainstream
team spotlight about six months old and
yet it's already sort of surpassed seed
round financing and dollar terms and I
think we're in sort of a high P moment
right now but over the long term I think
this trend is very real in here today so
I completely agree the speed with which
this has happened in the amount of money
getting diverted to it our mind boggling
has the distribution of capital into the
eye cos matched your model of innovative
technology no so what's actually driving
how off is it I I you know it's it's
kind of like a dartboard it's like a
fifty percent it's what you'd expect
it's like a fifty percent hit right so
like you know for example Tasos it's
it's you know I've talked about Tasers a
lot it's well known that we were there
first backer and kind of largest backer
you know long before they were known as
a public project they've now raised what
I think is the largest crowd sale of all
time over two hundred million dollars
and so in that sense I think the market
got it right I think it's one of the
most exciting crowd sales may be the
most exciting crowd sale that that's
happened and it also got sort of the
most money ever so to me it's like okay
the market was right maybe on accident
but the market was right there there are
other projects I don't want to bad-mouth
anyone specifically but there are lots
of other projects that are raised huge
amounts of money and have had huge
amounts of hype with very little real
progress beyond sort of an idea you know
Tasos like the white paper was written
in 2014 if you go back and read that
it's amazing how accurately it predicted
the future and a lot of problems that
would face major blockchain projects
like Bitcoin and you know a lot of the
new projects it's like they're rushing
to create a lot of height very quickly
and raise capital and it ultimately
feels like they're using it more like a
fundraising round and a way to amass
capital than a means of distributing
tokens and building a really powerful
user base in that
effect which I think the power of these
crowd sales is is that yes the yes you
can raise money this way but in a sense
crowd sales were originally a solution
to token distribution problem if you go
back in time before people did crowd
sales and math there was a project
called counterparty that did a proof of
burn and what this meant was they raised
Bitcoin and provably destroyed the
Bitcoin and this was just a means of
distributing the token and they didn't
hold that money which now feels like
almost a little silly it's like wow you
should have just held that money and
used it to fund development which is
what projects are doing now but it's
like this was actually first envisioned
as a means of distributing tokens and I
think a latter stage envisioned as a
means of fundraising and so I think that
a lot of these projects that are
structuring crowd sales also in ways
that incentivize a kind of first-come
first-serve mass rush for the doors
basically that all the excess value
between the cap on the crowd sale and
the eventual market price goes to
traders or like what I would maybe call
ticket scalpers rather than developers
or like authentic backers or users so so
there is a question from Twitter again
related to this so Jesse jump-cut asks
protocols like aetherium are exciting
for developers investors but not seeing
much excitement from actual users using
the apps what do you think yeah I think
it's accurate that right now we're
absolutely still in a speculative phase
more than anything I think this is true
by the way of Bitcoin and aetherium as
well not just kind of crowd sales but
that said I think a lot of these
services speculation actually is very
important to drive those eventual
network effects so there's two reasons
for this
so one is that a network effect building
a network effect has traditionally been
this this chicken-and-egg problem that's
like if I'm the first user on Instagram
it's not a very good service right but
if I'm the 10-million chooser on
Instagram
it's pretty good and if I'm like the
billionth user on Instagram maybe it's
great right but it really depends on
massing a crowd of people all at once in
order to kind of get off the ground and
Instagram had a very big launch day and
I think it's one of the reasons the
service has been successful over time so
by driving in a lot of early people just
through speculation I think you sort of
kind of bootstrap that Network effect in
a little bit more of like a raw way
where you have this whole speculator
base that in the future many of many of
them will become users and there's this
concept in Bitcoin that I think is sort
of new to this asset class where you see
in Bitcoin a lot of people speculating
on Bitcoin and also using Bitcoin and
they're like you know a holder user they
they're not they're speculating yes and
they have you know an unhealthy
percentage of their life savings in in
cryptocurrency but they're also really
fascinated by the technology and
actually experiment a lot with different
things and want to spend Bitcoin
whenever they can so I think you know
you bootstrap Network effects with
speculators and then over time the
network becomes authentically valuable
in the way that traditional networks
like Instagram become valuable and then
you kind of move from 95% speculation to
5% speculation over say 10 years of
something becoming useful the second
thing is that a lot of these services
depend on a market price and liquidity
in order to function so going back to
something like file coin with file coin
if I'm a hosting a node in the ipfs
Network and I need to actually you know
host I you know host all these various
servers for you know back-end the
backend servers for services like open
Bazaar shops right I need to know what
kind of like fixed cost can I put into
this and how much money can I expect to
receive from this and if file coins
don't have a clear price in like USD
where most of my fixed costs are going
to be denominated
with a relatively liquid market where I
know if I earn my file coin I can sell
it reliably it's very hard to know how
much to invest into this and it's very
hard to incentivize nodes to create high
uptime resilient high bandwidth nodes in
these various networks and this is like
Bitcoin mining you know it's very hard
to incentivize someone to mine Bitcoin
until they know how much Bitcoin is
worth right and then once you have these
liquid open markets that was a really
big part of what pushed Bitcoin to
become successful because before that
miners really couldn't they couldn't
liquidate Bitcoin and mining was sort of
a hobbyist thing no one was really going
to invest money in mining when there is
no clear outcome on in terms of what
it's worth in dollars and because many
of these services as they reach scale
rely on professional operators like node
operators or minors or validators
keepers whatever you want to call these
participants in the network that
actually support the network it's very
very important that they have a liquid
price and liquid markets so they can
invest in their businesses basically for
something like tezo's which has now you
know had over 200 million dollars in
funds raised how much of that how much
money do you think they actually need
are actually makes sense and I'm just
using them as an example for the
development of the company itself
underlying the protocol yeah absolutely
so and so and to be clear there's just a
non-profit foundation in Switzerland
similar to the structure of the etherium
foundation for Tasos so I think in the
old model of venture funding and
thinking about like how much cash does a
company need to execute on the TASIS
vision they absolutely don't need two
hundred million dollars they're really
smart team and they just don't need that
to execute some level of the vision now
that said the market is pricing k dose
at two hundred million dollar basically
market capitalization so a lot of people
have
called for teams to kind of cap their
crowd sales but the thing is that's
tricky about that model is that when you
cap a crowd sale at say 20 million which
may be in venture terms is more like the
amount something like Tasos would raise
now the market is going to take the
value to 200 million because that just
is the market demand for this for this
product right
but that means 180 million dollars of
excess value basically goes to these
traders or like ticket scalpers and it's
the same reason that like a some you
know Britney Spears concert sells out so
quickly on Ticketmaster it's not
authentic users it's people like coming
in for a trade they're they're going to
buy it quickly and then resell it and
this has two negative effects one is
that a huge amount of value actually
more value that then is captured by the
developer team is captured by basically
traders and I see no reason why that
value shouldn't be captured by the
developer team I would much rather have
Tasos have two hundred million dollars
than twenty million dollars I don't know
why the hundred eighty million should go
to traders the second aspect of that is
that you actually hurt your authentic
users who want to be either like a
long-term holder and follow the project
or like a developer who wants to tinker
with the taytay's those tokens you know
you you exclude them from the crowd sale
because the traders are sitting there
ready to make the click on the first
second they might have co-located nodes
around the world to participate on the
first block it's just hard to compete
with as a kind of regular user so while
I do think that these kind of uncap sale
like I chose raise more money than the
team strictly needs to execute the short
term or mid term vision I do think that
that value is going to go somewhere and
I would rather have it go to the
developer team than traders but isn't
that true at 200 million dollars as as
it is true at 20 million dollars that
the order of magnitude is different but
you could still have traders or
financial buyers speculators buying one
hundred and ninety million dollars worth
of the offering
versus you know 18 million dollars of
the 20 million in either scenario so you
could still have the vast majority owned
by speculators which might leave too
little there for the developers well and
so I think long-term speculators are
maybe okay like a group like poly chain
that buy stage shows and intends to hold
it for a very long time that's a little
bit that's a different group than what
I'm talking about which is that they're
very narrowly looking to basically
arbitrage between the capped crowd sale
limit and the eventual market price but
sorry I and I'm just pushing on this
because I don't I get that the size of
the number is different but there's
nothing is there something about let me
SS is there something about the way the
crowd cell was conducted that stopped
even short-term speculators from running
it okay so because the tasers crowd tail
was uncapped so there was no limit on
the amount it could raise that's why I
raised the two hundred million dollars
they put no limit which means that the
crowd sale participants put in their
capital it's two hundred million dollars
hypothetically
when tasers goes live and is traded on
markets it should trade it like two
hundred million dollars right there is
no like free trade or like upside
between the crowd sale and between being
listed on on liquid markets where when
you do a capped crowd sale where the and
you know cap crowd sale and the cap is
below the eventual market capitalization
once it reaches liquid markets every
single person that gets in on the crowd
tails eventually is basically getting a
free twinning trade right and that
creates bad incentives for people that
have no interest in the project they
don't know what the technology is there
not a long-term holder they're not a
user or anything to come in and purchase
the crowd sale and then just sell it
like literally days later I see so when
when does tase us go to liquid market
state Tasos probably will in about three
to four months okay it's not that I
agree that eliminates day trading but
three to four months is not a long term
positive holder like if you look at this
so if you are so your poly chain right
if there are other hedge funds out there
that are looking at these things and
they say yeah you know what three to
four months hold them you already have a
nine
hold time right or 90 day rebalancing
time like that is within very much
within the window of rebalance or
speculation so I love this idea that
saying okay no this is going to
incentivize the right kind of users to
come in but it feels as if if you really
wanted to do that you'd actually want
the liquid point to be something along
lines of a year or two or three or four
years out at which point a couple things
happen one there'll be enough
development on the protocol to make it
really usable and it'll start the
second-order effect of people building
things on top of the protocol and at
that point you go liquid the financial
speculators are washed out of that
market because they're not waiting three
years right but the developers were
really long-term minded right are happy
to hold for three years and if it's 200
million great if it's 20 million great
if it's a billion great so why not do
that why not say look we're going to
turn this into a liquid market in three
years so part of the reason is it just
it doesn't take three years to develop
the protocol so it'd be like an
artificial hold also the space changes
so quickly like keep in mind aetherium
was launched less than two years ago
like did not exist two years ago today
like just absolutely did not exist I
mean that it you know that kind of like
artificial hold period I think is maybe
like too long the other thing is that I
think it can be a little dangerous from
an execution perspective and we've seen
these problems with Kickstarter for
example where if you raise a bunch of
money like without building anything and
you say we're going to use the money to
build something sometimes you can't
execute and it results in really bad
outcome right whereas if they raise
money from only sophisticated investors
that understand the risk like a group
like poly chain which takes us did
before the crowd sale then the crowd
sale really acts as a distribution and
launch more than it is a fundraising
event to build the protocol if that
makes sense the other thing is that
these protocols are you know actively
maintained and developed
for years and years and years so they
launched moment while not arbitrary
obviously that's super important it's
just the beginning of a very long future
of adding features and and you know
efficiency improvements and all the rest
okay so then Jesse Jesse jump-cut asked
another question just about protocols in
general which one that you're excited
about so I'm very excited about zero X
zero X is a decentralized exchange in
order book that lives in an ethereal
smart contract so the idea is like my
former employer coinbase runs a
cryptocurrency exchange right but you
have to go to the centralized exchange
you know sign up create an account there
are some restrictions on like where
you're based in the world all sorts of
other things like that and there's just
like high friction and then you have to
know deposit money and you know trade on
a traditional centralized exchange and
then there's also historically big
counterparty risk here like mount GOx
which was hacked a lot of other
exchanges and won't name names have been
act and so it's actually sort of
dangerous to hold your phones on
centralized exchange in some cases I
think coinbase is is the best in the
world of security but when I when I look
at 0x it lives in a smart contract so it
allows you to basically
instantaneously trade between aetherium
and tokens or tokens for other tokens
natively in this aetherium smart
contract and because this is if you're
in our contract is just like a piece of
software it the 0x exchange capability
can be built into any application built
on aetherium so like if you're using
some casino game that takes specific
types of tokens in aetherium and you
like run out of those tokens you could
natively within the app use the 0x
protocol to exchange ether for tokens it
should take one block which in it
theorem is 17 seconds you now have your
new set of tokens and you can trade more
or you know play on this casino game or
something
so this idea of 0x and their exchange
protocol being actually baked into every
DAP or decentralized app that's built on
the etherion protocol is really amazing
to me so it just will facilitate this
extremely fluid exchange of token for
token and the ability to go from ether
to other token and token to another
token it's going to become very very
fluid it's going to be baked into the
user experience and it's going to take
like 17 seconds without needing to sign
up for centralized service or take on
any of the counterparty risk that you
take on holding your funds on a
centralized exchange so 0x I'm very
excited about I'm also really excited
about maker maker is pretty complicated
if this already wasn't all too
complicated so maker is trying to create
a stable coin so this coin is pegged to
the IMF currency basket which is trying
to itself is trying to be like a steady
basket of stable fiat currencies maker
is creating a token ERC twenty-year
theorem token called the dye the dye is
pegged to this currency basket and
there's there's kind of market
mechanisms that make the die either
harder or easier to create based on how
that how it's market price is pegged to
this currency basket so basically if it
becomes if it goes off the peg it
becomes harder or easier to issue dye in
order to keep it to that peg and what
you do when you issue dye is you
actually collateralize other aetherium
compatible assets so ether or aetherium
tokens in a smart contract in a value
that exceeds the dye you're creating so
if you want to create $1 worth of dye
you collateralized like a dollar 50
worth of ether right and so it's like
the diet is basically backed by
collateral that's held in smart
contracts as if you're incompatible
assets what this is getting at this is
all I know that's a lot at once what
this is getting at is a decentralized
stable coin so a coin that is well
to be free but isn't backed by like a
centralized bank account which is a huge
weakness from a compliance hacking
perspective from so many different
perspectives and so now if maker works
basically die issuance has an interest
rate and not interest rate gets paid to
maker holders maker holders also
determine in through a Dow structure so
like you know decentralized voting
structure what the interest rate and
collateral requirements are to create
die so the maker Dow which is the the
kind of decentralized organization that
decides those things is like a crypto
central bank for this decentralized
stable coin and I just find that concept
totally fascinating now this project is
very experimental amazing team behind
this but this is the type of thing that
I think we will see emerge over the next
few years is like volatility free crypto
coins and I think that's huge because if
you're going to see a lot of other
applications work like augers prediction
markets or open Bazaar just ecommerce
markets you need a stable sort of value
I mean you could bet in an auger
prediction market and be right but then
actually lose money because of
volatility right that's it's a horrible
experience or you know bad use your
experience it's going to really limit
the ability for those markets to gain
adoption and even for something like
open Bazaar where your money might be
held in escrow for a couple days you
might end up paying a lot more or less
than you thought or earning a lot more
or less than you thought in from an
e-commerce transaction which has very
narrow margins right you're talking
about three four percent margins in
e-commerce so to me something like
stable coin and the maker project is is
really exciting as well so yeah those
are a couple yeah are there other other
concerns you advise people to think
about whether they're they're going to
put money in I'm thinking chiefly on the
regular regulatory side right now but
both people developing tokens and
putting money into tokens so I I would
urge anyone who wants to invest into
to know what they're investing in and
really do their research and understand
that this is a basically experimental
and highly volatile market so don't you
know do anything unless you know what
you're doing basically for people that
are creating these things this is a much
longer conversation around you know do
you create a sort of parent entity like
a non-profit foundation where's that
foundation located globally the main
places that are turning out to be
friendly either from a regulatory and/or
tax perspective here are are Switzerland
the Cayman Islands Hong Kong Singapore
to an extent Gibraltar and then you know
there's a handful of teams experimenting
with other locales as well and I think
you know we have yet to see how that
sort of plays out I think that that is
yeah it's a longer conversation it
definitely okay if someone wants to dig
deeper what should they are there blogs
you read or what do you recommend they
yeah the problem is that just not that
many people have you even gone through
that process like you know and not that
many people have gone through in a
really legitimate way I think that the
ipfs team is is a really great resource
here so insofar as as one or Jesse from
that team has you're in blog posts or
like the coin list project which is a
partnership between ipfs and Angel list
I think there may be thinking about this
most carefully especially from a
us-centric perspective as well thank you
so much all off this was super
fascinating yeah thanks guys I can't
believe that the how it's already up
okay well yeah thanks for chatting
you